LAYLA EL-FAOULY
Marc! You have a choice!
MARC SPECTOR
I have to finish this.
If not, I'll never be free.
KEVIN FEIGE
With our Disney+ series, there were
characters who we
wanted to introduce for the first time.
Moon Knight was at the top of that list.
And we wanted a spectacular actor.
MARC SPECTOR
What the hell is wrong with you, Steven?
Stay out of my way.
STEVEN GRANT
Me? You're the one going on a
killing spree.
OSCAR ISAAC
Mohamed went for actors that
I think he just
intuitively know commit.
MOHAMED DIAB
I love May as an actress.
It was very important to me as an Arab
to find someone who can represent us.
[Screaming]
ANTONIA SALIB
Being half Egyptian myself,
it's great that I get to
play this mythical character.
KEVIN FEIGE
He's a much more action-oriented character
in a way we
haven't seen in the MCU.
ETHAN HAWKE
The form of movies is changing.
It's a movie on a larger canvas
with that level of cinema and quality.
OSCAR ISAAC
I would never have guessed that this
would be one of my
most creatively fulfilling adventures.
It was just amazing.
STEVEN GRANT
Oh man, this is mental.